well we're wrapping up my healthy habits
for the new year with one that really
applies to everyone but more often
speaks to women of all ages how well do
you love your body and how do you gauge
if it measures up
i think the best thing we can do is to
get out of the comparison race right so
even thinking to myself i'm every bit as
beautiful as she is or you know i still
measure up still means that we are
comparing ourselves to somebody else's
standard other than our own life coach
deb grayson regal says with different
body types different metabolisms and
different goals in life it's impossible
to define beauty the same and if you are
going to unlearn a lifetime of comments
about positive body means a certain size
or shape you've got to be really patient
with yourself and expect there to be
setbacks along the way regal says if you
have doubts try to analyze the internal
feedback you get when you see your
reflection so when you look at yourself
in the mirror ask yourself what you're
feeling am i feeling disappointed am i
feeling ashamed embarrassed and be
willing to to name it and then see if
you can replace it with a more helpful
healthier thought
social counselor jacob cooper says
keeping the spotlight on your own values
and what truly matters in your life will
shelter you from the negative noise
instead of focusing on what's outside
finding ways to set your own intentions
within your life and to focus on the
news that you want to create or the
story that you want to tell executive
life coach adam javlin says pick your
posse of positive people and avoid or
limit your time around those who aren't
make sure you're with the right people
friends family and
there is power and being able to like
i say with like a boxer bob and we go in
for a few minutes be with your loved
ones bow out because if you're hearing
negative enforcement
you can't sit in that you have to get
out deb regal says if you're seeking
positive change craft healthy goals and
keep them attainable body positivity may
be a little bit too far of a reach if
you've got it good for you for me i'm
working on body neutrality right so to
get from uh what is this too
this is me she urges ultimately as you
train yourself to love who you are
inside and out always try to set
yourself up for success i can get some
new clothes that make me feel awesome
is probably a healthier thought or you
can borrow mine which is
the necklace is always going to fit
great piece of advice the necklace does
always fit well all of the life coaches
that i spoke with say staying away from
the negative influences of social media
and the glam magazines help a lot too
some great advice there it's not always
easy to give yourself positive body talk
john heather